whatever the mind can envision these
nominees for visual effects can execute
and deliver they are ghostbusters
Richard Edlund John Bruno Marc Bargo and
Chuck Gaspar
Indiana Jones in the Temple of Doom
Dennis Muren michael mcallister Lauren
Patterson and George Gibbs 2010 Richard
Edlund Neal crapola Georg Jensen and
Mark Stetson the winners are Dennis
Muren michael mcallister Warren Peterson
and George Gibbs for Indiana Jones and
the Temple of Doom
well thank the Academy and Steven
Spielberg George Lucas Kathy Kennedy
Frank Marshall and Robert Watts
everybody Industrial like magic I'd like
to thank Elliott Scott the production
designer for asking me to work with him
and think Steven Spielberg they're
giving me the opportunity thank you
there's about other hundred other people
that I learned to think we don't have
time so I'd like to thank a few of them
they are Bruce Nicholson Michael Owens
barber Gallucci Pat Sweeney
Howie's Stein in the entire editorial
department and Pat Fitzsimmons and the
incredible Island grip Department thank
you but also like especially throne of
thanks for George Lucas it's our tenth
year this year and also Mont in the
model shop which is about 30 of us thank
you very much